next to a block of suburban homes is an
inconspicuous looking garage door
welcome to my home come on in inside is
a bright seemingly never-ending room
without dividing walls and enclosed by
exposed concrete and no one can see in
from the outside an important factor for
Alexandra depart for me he's this at the
moment I'm working an awful lot so when
I come home I want to come home to
somewhere with a red wine feeling you
should be able to come in and feel
relaxed it's somewhere for all the
different pleasures in life loose blue
glass don't loose a few steps up there's
the kitchen area the workspace looks
like a DJ's workplace
douwe de Diez that was the idea and
that's the inspiration for the project
named cj5 rather than DJ from cooking
Jay and since I really like cooking and
cook very elaborately when I have guests
I want to be able to keep communicating
with my guests so I got the idea of
building it into the landing and to bond
for them dancing horse every single
corner here is utilized this would be
shot we set out to create optimum
functionality in a minimal space you
pull that up you push it in and you have
more or less everything you need I'm a
tea drinker so to cut out the need for a
kettle I installed an instant boiling
water tap I've pulled the switch out
turn the whole thing and in two seconds
it reaches a hundred degrees Celsius
minimalist but very functional a little
higher up there's a bedroom with a small
all suite bathroom
the bathtub has been sunk into the floor
to save space
the owner loves the view from up here
I've got a few special things that you
don't notice the windows behind me are
built in such a way that when they're
open the Sun shines directly onto my bed
in the morning I wake up bathed in
sunlight from the bedroom a corridor
leads on to a terrace the roof of his
low-energy house is equipped with solar
panels
there's also plenty of space to relax
outdoors I treated myself to an outdoor
shower too it's connected to warm water
so I can shower there once temperatures
rise to 14 degrees the architecture
means that I can sunbathe in the nude
and then shower afterwards it's very
handy the atrium can also be covered if
required the house is very versatile and
has over 150 square meters of living
space although it's only 5 meters wide
but eggs and egg a pod often entertains
friends this is where my drinks fridge
is hidden it has the advantage that
people don't have to go rummaging around
in my regular fridge the seller doubles
as a private cinema and party venue on
exam bag a pot has thrown quite a few
parties here and has already had to
replace a white carpet
the cj5 on the edge of Vienna outside it
keeps a low profile but inside it's both
elegant and practical